good morning job it's very very early
Christmas and so Katherine and I have
come together to answer people's
Christmas questions we like Christmas
yes we do yeah I mean Taha wants to know
is it like the films I've never
experienced Christmas thing with people
who celebrate Christmas you mean like
die hard cuz it's exactly like die hard
everybody to the Christmas party by
mistake was another good Christmas movie
It's a Wonderful Life
the well I haven't seen that one what
I'll give you the moon all right take it
I've seen parts of it I've never watched
the whole thing
I got the sense that it was a real
downer and that's not what I want at
Christmas I mean there's like feasts and
there's opening presents and there's
stockings and all the tropes are there
you eat spaghetti with maple syrup and
cotton ball whose idea was it to bring a
tree inside and then decorate it Oh
Germans yeah yeah around that area
Germany didn't exist right but like the
Germanic I think the idea was it's the
middle of winter and we're depressed so
we need some green up in here
Springs a long time away I was reading
that they would hang trees from the
ceiling right well you know the house is
small so you probably couldn't really
have a lot of floor space too right
before they had the trees and also
people who couldn't afford a full tree
would just have like pine boughs love
affair with a monado's to have been
Christmas we were talking about it now
which means Katherine's going to cry for
a while I'll be back in a little bit the
thing that I have a problem with
Christmas is that it's comes as done
it's over bye-bye oh yeah and you're
like yeah we did though we were prepped
for so long I got all this stuff in my
house no I leave it up for Christmas and
much most of January when you can blow
on the tree and the needles fall off oh
gosh that's too late that's really
dangerous actually you shouldn't do that
have you ever seen a Christmas tree fire
there's lots of YouTube videos in fact
I'll put one right here right now I
didn't like it where do I get
last-minute Christmas presents what do
you got in your cupboard didn't use that
soap yet here's some Irish Spring yeah
carve it with a napkin these
stripes are to die over and to get a man
freshen did you know that Turtles all
the way down was named a best book of
the Year by the New York Times The Wall
Street Journal Entertainment Weekly Time
magazine and PR BuzzFeed Amazon Barnes &
Noble the Union AV Club Publishers
Weekly and book list and it's available
at bookstore you lot of congratulations
like all the lists are there any more or
less what do people in summer climates
do for Christmas same stuff yeah I mean
without the sweater is probably
traditional to have a fruitcake because
the world is terrible I think it was
special to have fruit this time of year
where is the fruit come from
oh it's dried you put a bunch of booze
in it that's your mince mince you think
it means and it's like being able to eat
a fruit in the middle of winter it's not
exactly like it let's but it's the
Crillon is as close as you can get what
do Americans do on Boxing Day what do
you call that we call it the day after
Christmas and we go back to work you
bring the boxes out you put all your
Christmas decorations in them and that's
Boxing Day what's the deal with the
pickle do you know what the deal with
the pickle is cuz several people asked
about the pickle are they messing with
us
is there a Christmas pickle is like Gigi
the Christmas snake thank you for your
questions Thank You Catherine for being
here any time not really you know once a
year think John we'll see you on Tuesday
bang another very good table that like
demanding figgy pudding there was
sailing you a viewing all over the town
eating fruit and getting drunk you Wasel
did the winces loss estate what how was
it
refrigerator is why are they just called
frigerators oh i hate Christmas